ce qui a commencé ici c'est le
détonateur dix plaintes d'une chatte ans
la réforme oui la chienlit non
la caricature est trop vrai et le chat
de pompey foutraque et créer une
dynamique une solidité quelque chose de
l'habituel et will encore prise de
conscience la violence qu'on n'avait pas
connu ici depuis longtemps
ça faisait le bilan de la nuit
dramatique du quartier latin
évidemment j'ai pas mal de pluie
[Musique]
il faut être honnête la fin du monde
nous pendait au nez pourtant c'est pas
faute d'avoir essayé avant que tout
parte à vau l'eau de le changer ce foutu
monde changer le cours des événements un
coup pavé dans la mare et pas toujours
des vrais pas vers saint germain les
pavés de l'émeute valent les années 60
c'était quand même une sacrée ambiance
les mouvements de contestation partout
des sociaux les anti guerre des
antiracistes des anti autoritaire à
l'est et des anticapitalistes à l'ouest
ne jetez plus de pavés la cour est
pleine culturel ou économique
étudiants ouvriers pour les droits
civiques les libertés ou juste tout
[ __ ] en l'air une vraie ambiance de
fin du monde ou plutôt la faim dans mon
l'ancien en france bien sûr il ya eu un
mouvement de 68 au moment de rupture
historique je crois tout de même qu'il
faut ramener l'événement à ses justes
proportions
mais étrangement le pays avait pas
attendu le mois de mai pour se diviser
le vote ne fabrique je crois un premier
pavé venaient de fracturer les écrans de
lower tf vous savez la télé bien sage et
police et d'une france c'est pas
n'importe laquelle celle du général de
vous même si un directeur j'aurais vous
demandez actuellement quatre coins du
monde se déroulent de nombreux
événements des équipes de la nfl sont
envoyés et j'aimerais savoir si ces
équipes ont une totale liberté face à
leur porter nos journalistes à
l'étranger se sente ce qu'ils sont c'est
à dire les représentants des organismes
qui est un service public français et
qui peu ou plus représentent un petit
peu la france et voilà que le bien nommé
service de la recherche nos condé de
bien drôles d'oiseaux dans un dessin
animé expérimental pour dire le moins
qui a pas laissé les français
indifférents ça a été une nouvelle
affaire dreyfus les gens envoyé les
lettres disait l'échalote et où c'est
une émission immonde le dessin n'est pas
beau les auteurs sont des analphabètes
la moitié évidemment de ces lettres sont
maîtres pour l'autre moitié sont des
lettres kong
quoi qu'on en pense on seulement ou quoi
trois saisons plus une dernière produite
en 2000 l'histoire à la retenue les
shadoks comme une révolution créative
une tentative de renverser une télé plan
plan est peut-être un peu embourgeoisé
avec pour seule arme un humour plutôt
british un style minimaliste et une
technique d'animation novatrice puisque
vraiment ils sont pauvres ou est-ce
qu'il gaspille l'argent du
téléspectateur que vous en voyez
toujours d'ailleurs signale que s'arrête
doublé avant la fin de l'année dix mille
francs par an pour regarder la
télévision
avec le recul quel meilleur représentant
d'une époque d'effervescence et
d'expérimentation une oeuvre décrié en
son temps qui laissera pourtant la trace
indélébile de ces grandes pattes dans
l'histoire les shadoks c'était avant
tout un joli coup d'autodérision sur les
français eux mêmes plus c'est l'auto
interrogations les gens s'interrogent et
en face vous vous souvenez il y avait
les gimmicks avec un petit chapeau sur
la tête pour pouvoir se dire bonjour
élégant cultivé qui se moque de ces
rustres de shadoks
jbe pour grande bretagne si vous prenez
le caractère français je crois que ce
que je critique surtout pour un rien on
se fâche on arrache l'épave est en
érigent des barricades va
c'était un cri enchante les shadoks
c'est aussi une concurrence farouche
entre ces deux blocs pour construire
quoi elle fonctionne grâce à un
combustible superpuissant le cosmo gun
990 mais quel est ce combustible miracle
d'où des jbe l'extrait est dans le camp
shadoks on avait d'ailleurs un endroit
où le chef suprême vous pouvez envoyer
ce qui ne satisfaisait pas et le team
époux poule
cette écharpe âges autour d'un simple
dessin animé ça a vraiment pris des
proportions nationales jusqu'à mobiliser
même la femme du général en personne
ça faisait quand même une jolie
répétition générale avant le mois de mai
qui allaient déchiré bien plus
sérieusement et durablement l'hexagone
mais qui plaira bien moins ils veulent
au milieu de ce mouvement étudiant et
ouvriers d'une ampleur sans précédent et
de ses symboles de révolte qui
fleurissent partout mais qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve nos petits piaf ridicule
les shadoks réquisitionné à leur tour
par les travailleurs en lutte
pas si étonnant que ça malgré le fait
que les shadoks sous initialement pensé
comme les méchants de l'histoire façade
et jpy plus civilisé ou même que jacques
rouxel s'est toujours défendu de faire
de la politique savait pas de quoi
désespérer billancourt
comment des millions de grévistes
auraient pas pu se reconnaître dans ces
êtres qui me paie mon père
c'était un symbole parfait de
l'aliénation au travail et cj bila
méprisant oisif qui les prennent de haut
de leur culture et de leurs hôtes forme
comment ils n'auraient pas pu y voir
leurs exploiteurs après tout pourquoi
pas puisque l'époque est à l'inversion
des valeurs et les shadows qu'au fond
c'est ça on se marre de voir l'absurdité
de leur société et ces valeurs qui leur
semble a eu tout à fait décisive pour
nous que nous adoptons anello ceux d'en
bas la récupérer de quoi plaire aux
travailleurs exploités qui rejettent
leurs conditions jade octobre a dû comme
vous le savez soutenait la planète s'en
plaignait mais aussi aux étudiants
contestataires avides de questionner les
symboles et les valeurs de l'ancien
monde qu'il y ait le moins de mécontents
possible il faut toujours taper sur les
mêmes et puis avec un chouïa d'humilité
ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu apprendre des
shadoks
vous savez avec leur semaine de loisirs
avant d'aller travailler le week end ou
leur volonté un peu dingue de toujours
essayer et pour essayer sa vison essayé
on peut pas leur enlever avec ce genre
de raisonnement typiquement aux shadoks
bon d'accord maintenant on en est là et
il en reste coi bain des traces des
images des affrontements dans le
quartier latin
des piquets de grève des slogans et de
devises pourquoi faire simple quand on
peut faire compliqué les questionnements
et les revendications d'une époque on en
trouve l'empreinte dans les imaginaires
politique comme dans la culture
populaire elle qui est à la fois le
produit l'époque qui s'est emparée
d'elle en retour alors ok ils ont
peut-être pas sauver le monde mais ils
l'ont changée en bousculant une vieille
télé poussiéreuse où un ordre social en
apportant une poésie contre la grisaille
et une soif d'autre chose oiseaux de
mauvais augure pour certains sans doute
ceux pour qui le changement n'augurait
rien de bon
des idées nouvelles peut-être folle à
moins que ce soit notre monde qui était
fou juste s'en rendent et peut-être pas
content et on a cherché des formes
certes un peu de l'ordinaire
et ça ça fait mal car c'était un
disciple de base
j'adore ce n'est qu'en essayant
continuellement que l'on finit par
réussir dans d'autres termes tous arras
on a de chances que sa femme
[Musique]